hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about the four main causes of what
could make your body feel cold whether
it's cold feet or cold hands or your
body's just cold okay
so the number one is slow thyroid an
underactive thyroid that can be as a
Hashimoto's condition which is an
autoimmune or just a slow thyroid gland
because the thyroid hormones control the
speed of your metabolism the rate of how
fast that machine is burning fuel okay
so if it's slow then you can be cold but
there's some underlying causes to
thyroid it could be high levels of
estrogen okay that's why when women they
get pregnant or they have a baby they
spiked estrogen all of a sudden they end
up with a thyroid problem or it could be
they're taking estrogen birth control
pills or hormone replacement therapy or
they're just estrogen dominant that can
that alone can cause a thyroid condition
or it could be your liver or your
gallbladder if you're missing a
gallbladder or you have a sluggish
gallbladder or a liver problem that can
prevent the conversion of t4 to t3 so
you got to look at what's deeper so
number two low blood Sugar's this is
called hypoglycemia very easy to fix the
way to fix it is not to consume six
meals a day or eat sugar when your your
blood Sugar's are low I put a link down
below of exactly what you should eat to
correct this but that will bring up the
temperature number three low iron that
could be because you're anemic let's say
you have a heavy period and you're
losing blood and you're becoming anemic
that way because you're estrogen
dominant it could also be low stomach
acids where you need to increase the
acids in your stomach to pull this
mineral back in your body because in
order to absorb iron you need a very
acidic stomach okay ALP cider vinegar is
really good but taine how to chloride is
really good as well and it also could be
that you're vegetarian because animal
products deliver a certain type of iron
that builds up the hemoglobin and yet
even though there's iron in vegetables
it's a different type of iron and lastly
it could be low vitamin b1 or low
vitamin b12 okay this could be a source
of a neem a different type of anemia but
B 1 and B 12 deficiencies
can be created by consuming too much
alcohol okay that's a big one or
consuming too much sugar or experiencing
too much stress or certain medications
could do it as well or it could come
from having anorexia or bulimia so here
are some things to look at if you're too
cold to potentially help you thanks for
watching hey thank you so much for
watching keep spreading the word and
share this video